amber Ashworth I had a nickel for every  time this broad got me into trouble  do we really have to do this whole bit  again it's growing from the same aren't  you perceptive dog you should have been  a detective let's pretend there's  something inside like like a Golden  Retriever puppy just for you doll oh my  god is it really yeah no it was a joke  my mom uses the same one to wash Ted in  what that's not true I have a shower in  my office oh you do do you  wait it's locked  what this is mighty suspicious don't  miss I'm afraid your brother is missing  what should we do Ted we have to find  him  Myers is like the whole damn City is  having that night hold on there soon  well it's just that this guy is not your  average Santa see god damn it I have to  talk to the mayor personal the word on  the street is that the suspect codename  red is asking a lot of questions about  Miss Ashworth oh my god Ted is in my  house  you